1774 in King Louie the 15th for France
is dead and his grandson louis xvi
succeeds him France at this point was
Europe's greatest power something which
they wished to continue keeping this
position from other European powers was
costly and led to a series of expensive
Wars which essentially bankrupted France
at the top of the French government's at
the king the clergy in the nobles who
together are known as the ancien régime
the ancien régime mostly didn't pay
taxes which meant financing france's
position fell to everyone else mostly
the poor this period also saw the height
of the Enlightenment prominent French
political philosophers such as
Montesquieu Russo and Voltaire were
challenging the political status quo one
major aspect of this was the Kings
divine right to rule
which meant that the king was king
because that was what God wanted so
therefore shut up and do what he says
ideas that challenge Divine Right to
rule came from Britain with this
constitutional monarchy and from the
newly formed United States who had
decided that Kings really weren't that
necessary Frances aid to the American
Revolution had secured independence for
the colonies and had struck a blow
against Frances great rival this however
was not a cheap blow and through France
into even greater economic hardship
Louie appointed a series of finance
ministers to fix the country's tax woes
but all failed simply because they
couldn't get the clergy or the nobility
to pay taxes the peasantry were now
starting to get restless
since these tax problems hit them the
hardest a harvest fairly led to the
price of bread skyrocketing and riots
broke out France was now in crisis and
so Louis called for the Assembly of the
estates-general which was a major
legislative assembly which had not met
for over 150 years it represented the
three great estates of France the first
estate the clergy the second estate the
nobility and the Third Estate everybody
else no solution could be found so in
order to speed things up King Louie
simply locked the Third Estate out
because they were the ones who wanted
change the Third Estate then gathered in
a nearby tennis court where they swore
to continue meeting until a new
constitution was established
unsurprisingly King Louie opposed all of
this but the people were much more
supportive from from the National Guard
to protect the Third Estate now called
the National Assembly against violent
retaliation to do so they famously
stormed the Bastille to free prisoners
but mostly to get guns the National
Assembly now called the National
Constituent Assembly issued the
Declaration of the Rights of Man and
citizen which established the rights of
the French people what makes this so
important is that these rights came from
the people not from the king or God the
bread situation did not improve
as such more riots broke out a rumor
started the royal family were hoarding
food and has such rioters mostly women
marched on the palace of versaille after
a standoff and some violence the king
and his Austrian wife the distained
Marie Antoinette agreed to return to
Paris where they'd be closer to the
people the revolutionary started to
punish the clergy in the nobles the
church could no longer levy taxes and
the revolutionaries also introduced a
non religious calendar many Nobles fled
to neighboring countries and had their
lands and wells confiscated these
revolutionaries should not be seen as
unified however they had different ideas
on what France should be most
revolutionary such as the Marquis de
Lafayette wanted to keep the monarchy
but the Jacobin led by center maximilien
robespierre wanted its complete
abolition altogether after two years
back in a captain with much less power
louis decided to flee to the protection
of his brother-in-law holy roman emperor
leopold ii the royal family were
recognized on the way in sent back to
paris where they were seen as enemies of
the revolution which they were Louis and
his wife's close ties with Austria meant
that the revolutionaries were becoming
concerned with external threats to make
matters worse the Austrians and
Prussians issued the Declaration of
Units which gave their support to Louis
against the Revolution this declaration
was used as a pretext to war or though
Robespierre opposed it and in April 1792
France invaded the Austrian Netherlands
beginning the War of the first coalition
this was a victory for France with only
Britain refusing to make peace France
annexed the Austrian Netherlands and
invaded the Dutch Republic which after a
popular uprising became the Batavian
Republic one of France's sister
republics which were essentially puppet
States shortly afterwards a second
coalition this time with added Russia
with declare war on France but again it
was a French victory back in France the
revolution also cracked down on internal
threats in 1792 the king was deposed and
a republic declared he was later put on
trial for treason and sentenced to death
by one vote Louis was beheaded by
guillotine in January 1793 Emery met the
same fate shortly afterwards Louie's
death will be the first in the most
famous phase of the revolution the reign
of terror this was a period of mass
suspicion where neighbor would accuse
neighbour of betraying the revolution
not seeming supportive enough was enough
to have you arrested the period also saw
the execution of over 40,000 people many
by guillotine power at this point rested
with the committee for public safety
which was led by Robespierre the terror
became more and more power
until Robespierre himself was arrested
and executed but not before being shot
in the face after the fall of
Robespierre there was a period of
stability when a new government the
directory was formed this would last for
five years before it was overthrown by a
famous general Napoleon Bonaparte who
has subsequently declared First Consul
of France Napoleon had risen to
prominence due to his successful
military career he first defeated the
British at Toulon before leading a
successful invasion of Italy he was not
always successful though as demonstrated
by his 1798 invasion of Egypt which is
rebelling against rule by the Ottoman
Empire Napoleon wanted Egypt to act as a
launch pad for invading British colonies
in Asia but harassment by ottoman and
British forces meant that he had to
return home achieving nothing after his
coup Napoleon oversaw a series of
domestic reforms one of the greatest
changes to the government was that the
bureaucrats and military officers were
now promoted based on merit not birth to
ensure the loyalty of those promoted
Napoleon created the National order of
the Legion of Honour which people were
admitted into based upon good service he
also sought to undo some of the harm
done to the church by the revolution by
restoring some power to it but
ultimately answered to him some of
Napoleon's most important changes were
to the military the French army was
composed of conscripts who were gathered
using france's efficient bureaucracy the
french army saw its administration
improved specifically how orders were
relayed the army developed a more
effective medical service able to stem
the outbreak of epidemics as well as a
sophisticated supply train which meant
that the soldiers no longer had to live
off the land as much in 1804 Napoleon
was declared the Emperor of the French
formally ending the first French
Republic and beginning the first French
Empire the next year he had himself
crowned the king of Italy which would
act as a catalyst for another coalition
against France this war the war the
third coalition was the first of the
Napoleonic Wars and one of the most
famous Britain had been an enemy of
France since forever and the pole Ian
was keen to knock it out at the war to
do so he amassed a huge army on France's
northern coast but for an invasion to
happen the Pollin had to neutralize
Britain's greatest strengths the Royal
Navy interestingly in order to finance
the war Napoleon sold his North American
territories to the United States the
United States borrowed some of this
money from British banks which meant
that the British were essentially
funding a French invasion of themselves
any hope of invading Britain was ended
when the French and their ally Spain's
combined fleet was destroyed at the 1805
battle
Trafalgar Napoleon fared significantly
better on land against the continental
powers the army waiting to invade
Britain marched into the Holy Roman
Empire and after some clever maneuvering
managed to secure the surrender of an
Austrian army with very little bloodshed
before capturing Vienna the remnants of
the Austrian army joined up with the
Russians under Emperor Alexander
Napoleon gave the impression that his
army was in shambles which made the
Allies confident enough to meet him at
the battle of Austerlitz here Napoleon
won one of his greatest victories
securing an Austrian surrender this
victory also saw the end of the Holy
Roman Empire which was dissolved shortly
afterwards becoming the Confederation of
the Rhine another French puppet state
French dominance would upset the
Prussians who would shortly afterwards
begin the war of the fourth coalition
bad idea
French victory here saw the creation of
a semi-independent polish state called
the Duchy of Warsaw which was carved
from Prussian territory at this point
Napoleon had a firm grip over most of
Europe and he demanded that all those
under his influence join the Continental
System which was essentially a trade
embargo aimed at bankrupt in Britain
Portugal Britain's closest ally was
reluctant to join into the French with
their Spanish allies invaded in 1807
forcing the Portuguese royal family to
flee to Brazil Spain was undergoing its
own problems and sensing weakness
Napoleon invaded Spain itself and
installed his brother Joseph on the
throne the British then landed in
Portugal where both nations teamed up
with the Spanish rebels against the
French beginning the Peninsular war
which would last for six years
simultaneously the Austrians undeterred
by France never losing began the war of
the fifth coalition which France
shockingly won giving them this
territory
three years later Russia was getting
sick of being told what to do and so
started trading with Britain again
Napoleon support for the neighbouring
Duchy of Warsaw also meet our Alexander
nervous of a possible French invasion
this fear was well-founded since in 1812
the French invaded Russia with a huge
army numbering over half a million
Napoleon won many costly victories and
occupied Moscow the Russians however had
destroyed everything of value as they
retreated and when winter came around
the ponies army froze and starved
forcing him to retreat Napoleon's
failure and Russia led to the major
powers of Europe plus the now
independent United Netherlands forming a
sixth coalition against the French
this time the coalition's to defeat
Napoleon and occupied Paris the
Peninsular war also ended with an allied
victory in Spain became an independent
nation again Napoleon then abdicated and
was subsequently exiled to the island of
Elba shortly afterwards Lu
the sixteenths brother also called Louie
because why rock the boat at this point
was crowned lure the 18th but unlike the
previous monarchy this one was bound by
a constitution strangely Napoleon was
not happy with his exile and managed to
escape Albert and returned to France
Louie the 18th bravely ran away to
Britain and Napoleon resumed his
position as Emperor the countries that
had just defeated the French were none
too happy about this and so formed the
seventh coalition the coalition was
victorious and Napoleon suffered his
most famous defeat here by a joint
Prussian British army at Waterloo and
shortly afterwards was exiled to st.
Helena off the coast of Africa where he
remained until his death in 1821
afterwards the main powers of Europe
established the act of Vienna which
removed Frances conquests and tried to
establish a balance of power in Europe
the idea was to prevent a single nation
from becoming too powerful and to
prevent future Wars which went
swimmingly the legacy of the French
Revolution was a fundamentally different
France his Republican ideals would never
go away
it made Napoleon's rise to power and the
subsequent Wars possible which saw
France rise to its highest heights but
his downfall would leave Britain almost
unchallenged for the next 100 years I
hope you enjoyed this video and thank
you for watching